en el último vídeo propuse que esta
fórmula es sumamente útil para encontrar
anti derivadas de cierto tipo de
funciones
veamos si esto realmente funciona
calculemos entonces la anti derivada de
x
x de x y si te fijas en la fórmula
quieres asignar a una parte de esto a fx
y otra parte de esto ag prima de x la
pregunta es el signo f xx que prima de x
a coseno de x o f x a coseno de x ig
prima de x a x y para esto hay que darse
cuenta en la otra parte de la fórmula
que esencialmente tenemos que resolver
esta parte de aquí y aquí tenemos la
derivada de f x x gdx lo que tenemos que
hacer es asignar a fx de tal manera que
la derivada de fx es más simple que fx y
asignar que prima de x de tal manera que
si tomamos su anti derivada no se
complica más en este caso si tomamos fx
como x
efe prima de x va a ser 1 con lo cual se
hace más simple la expresión por lo que
se prima de x corresponde a coseno de
y su anti derivada es seno de x con lo
cual no se complica la expresión si lo
hiciéramos al revés que fx fuera coseno
de x
efe prima de x es menos en de x la
expresión no se complica pero sí que
prima de x es igual a x la anti derivada
gdx es x cuadrada sobre 2 y eso lo hace
más complicado vamos a plantearlo
claramente por acá entonces tenemos que
fx es igual a x f x es igual a x por lo
que este prima de x es igual a 1
mientras que mi prima de x voy a usar
otro color de prima de x es igual a
coseno de x por lo que guede x es igual
a seno gx es igual a seno de x la anti
derivada de coseno de x ahora dadas
estas asignaciones veamos como aplicar
esta fórmula
hagámoslo entonces por acá abajo del
lado derecho tenemos fx por gd x fx es
igual a x entonces aquí sería x porque x
gx
seno de x x x seno de x - menos la anti
derivada de f prima de x la anti
derivada de prima de x pero efe prima de
x es uno por gx gx es seno de x
lxs x de x esto es una gran
simplificación teníamos que encontrar la
anti derivada de x
de x y ahora tan solo tenemos que
encontrar la anti derivada de seno de x
y sabemos que la anti derivada de seno
de x la antidiva de seno de x de x es
igual a menos coseno de x y por supuesto
más nuestra constante integración que
vamos a sumar aquí al final ya que
tenemos toda nuestra anti derivada
entonces esto es igual a
x
seno de x
menos
la anti derivada de seno de x dx que
calculamos por la ya que va a ser menos
x
más se podemos agregar se restan se como
sea ésta es una constante que inclusive
puede ser negativa y está entonces es
igual a podemos escuchar las fanfarrias
x
seno de x
más coseno de x más c y hemos terminado
hemos encontrado la anti derivada de
algo que hasta ahorita no sabíamos cómo
hacer esto es realmente interesante